hi guys today we're going to be doing a
spoiler free examination on one of the
two characters I'm most excited to see
in season 4 and that of course is me Rio
I'm gonna be doing it in a single minute
in these 60 seconds we're going to
explore his childhood his relationships
obviously his quirk and his rise from an
average student in class 1b to a
character regarded by many many fans and
also characters in universe as a
potential future number one hero now
there's going to be a time on the screen
so you know it's actually one minute but
my real subscribe is know I would never
lie before we begin though whether
you're an anime only fan or a manga
enthusiast like myself subscribe to this
channel if you love my hero academia I
have a ton of interesting videos already
just as a quick example last week I did
the top 5 all my death theories but I've
done a ton of other ones and there's
more coming over the coming weeks and
months so please subscribe also as usual
anyone who retweets or shares this video
on Twitter automatically has their
handle included in the end credits of my
next video last week we had quite a few
retweets so as you can imagine the end
credits this week will be very long but
let's get into the video shall we after
being saved from drowning as a small
child maria was inspired to become a
hero however he was both blessed and
cursed with a power that had potential
to be great but was more likely to
injure or kill him this power is
permeation which basically allows him to
face through things sort of like vision
from the Marvel movies Mario's dad
actually had the exact same quirk but
gave up on becoming a hero because as he
put it one wrong move could literally
snap you in half this is further alluded
to by the fact that mario has a myriad
of scars all over his arms in terms of
personality his defining traits are his
optimism his goofiness and crucially his
ability to accept his own weaknesses
while we were introduced to him as a
character who could defeat class one day
single-handedly we got a glimpse of his
countless string of embarrassing
failures beforehand he was an average
student but he not only trained hard but
put real time and thought into how he
could make his power great Mario's best
friend is Tamaki and the two have
arguably the best and longest-running
permits of any student their
personalities are very contrasting but
they always set each other up and
combined with Ned's array they referred
to as the big three being the best
students at UA miryo being top of the
pack and that was me Ryo in one minute
well slightly more than one minute
probably like one minute and three
seconds as you could tell I was rushing
at the end there but we're gonna see him
in the big three do some serious damage
in season four one thing that there
literally wasn't any time to mention was
that his hero name is actually Lilian
honestly it was just too many syllables
to fit in I reckon if he had a hero name
like deku it might have been okay but
yeah but the reason he's called 'la
million is because he basically wants to
save a million people by the time he's
retired as a hero which is a pretty
noble cause so you know I can get behind
that if you guys like this video then
I'll definitely do a part two in the
future when I can talk about manga
spoilers and spoilers from season four
and potentially that time it will be two
minutes so you know I don't have to rush
so much but yeah don't forget to
subscribe I have a new video coming out
next week potentially this week even
because I'm gonna do a overhaul in one
minute video as well so we'll see when I
released that but yeah thanks to
everyone who retweeted my last video the
name should be currently on the screen
and remember that if you want your
username to be included in my next video
all you have to do is just share this on
Twitter I'll alter matically see it so
peace out thank you for watching